just attributed to do what dude hey guys
Ryan right here hello Veronica
this is our first video alone in our new
apartment
oh and I thought what better video to do
together that another Mortal Kombat X
trailer my girlfriend loves violence
really [ __ ] us saw Halloween that
she's into torture porn I'm into regular
porn she's into like torture porn oh I
didn't even know that something like
that existed yeah it's called like saw
and hostile there isn't such a thing as
a category oh there is some sex happen
anyway this is a brutality trailer
ah
[Music]
oh my god it's so violent oh my god
[Music]
how was Batman
people really like oh baby why stop
there there's so many of these trailers
I have to show you you oh my god baby
look this one might be a little bit more
calm down it's a story trailer I haven't
seen any the story trailers yet okay so
we are watching more right now yeah okay
why do you separate videos and piss off
fans throwing us all in one video just
play the damn thing it's two minutes
great it's to retain the story even in
three seconds
tashi Takeda Jacqueline Briggs
Khun Jean you are not welcome here
from zero let's talk Cassandra you lead
this group but they do not follow until
you function as one who will fall short
our village was the epicenter of a
theistic talisman percentage growth and
those cotton emissions
if this talisman is what I have
suspected to be we may all pay a price
[Music]
little push and a who rebel bomb
she has anywhere it's just not a lot of
production wish to steal my needs are
[Music]
okay guys standard diamond formation
Takeda you on point Jackie bring up the
rear
what makes you
[Music]
don't know about you guys but I'm living
a dream
[Music]
sweet ah how sweet lies with you
[Music]
she's super familiar with all the Mortal
Kombat's she knows exactly what's going
on
I didn't realize there's a whole
storyline to it I thought it was just
okay let's turn it on and then I pick my
character and then we fight there's a
whole story to it they'd be the story
I think the cinematic effects could be
better to be honest guys like it lose
okay cinematic effects
I mean it looks executed in an
incredibly cheesy way but that actually
works because the violence is so over
the top so it would seem more disturbing
if the cinematic effects were like
really serious and good but the
cheesiness adds to the flavor um to be
completely honest I thought it was all
pretty badass oh you did I kind of
changed I'm thinking about it a little
bit really I thought it was just
brutality like horrible disgusting like
I got all these characters and creatures
and there's those there's usually a
cinematic storyline before everything
whoa oh so so they tell you the story
and then you fight or you actually play
as like play through the journey yeah
from what I recall I haven't played in a
while but from what I recall there is
like you start a fight with someone and
then it's show like a little bit of
story it's like when you play in the
character then you go through their
journey yeah like how they're connected
and stuff all right well it's still
[ __ ] up anyway guys yeah those are
your two videos for you if you're new to
the channel you mean if turneth on on
silent
babe sorry gosh I feel so embarrassed
for you right now are you gonna use the
whip on me tonight for being a bad boy
thank you hey guys if you didn't
Chandler you can subscribe to the real
rejects but ronica has a channel to you
there's a lot of vlogs and music covers
you should check that channel out it's a
lot of fun and we're gonna do a shout
out right now baby what baby there's a
few girls that have recently commented
hmm one on Twitter one on Instagram and
one on YouTube and um you know I wanted
to acknowledge them in this shout-out
but first let's just read some comments
there's cohab little monster she looks
Jewish hey Soph the star of cheap stuff
food cycle sorry David and she was just
saying like you're probably my favorite
youtuber right now and yeah she's a
Deadpool Kathy on Instagram said that
she's a little jelly of you cuz she
thinks i'm quite handsome and then this
girl said babe blur said Ryan I think
you're such a hottie please give me a
shout-out so here's why I am addressing
this with you cuz I can't lie to my
girlfriend
if babes want me you do what you gotta
do ladies but I'm sorry I'm committed
I'm committed that's why I brought you
here baby
oh so that way I don't have to tell
[Music]
I don't have to tell you like oh this
girl said missing what am I really like
talking to them and stuff no I am saying
like thank you it's flattering
I appreciate it it boosts my ego yes of
course anytime someone says I'm
good-looking gay guy or female I'm gonna
feel better but stray away from the Ray
I mean Ryan my name is Ryan it's not
ready why did you say right because I
was saying the word gay I know really oh
no he's just a hot piece of ass I really
know like trust me I know yeah I mean
yeah my ass is nice that is the sweetest
thing ever
Faden no problem you see I thought I
should do this for the Mortal Kombat X
video where none of the girls are gonna
be watching Joe King they'll be watching
play watch all my videos
okay they watch all my you're a punk-ass
[ __ ] no baby no baby yeah punk-ass no
baby
punk-ass mother [ __ ] no no oh and
since we're being all sweet and stuff
Porsha one of Veronica's girls that she
babysits made me these boxes that look
awesome
so shout out to you Porsha oh you
shouldn't be watching this video
hopefully Veronica just skipped at the
end for you